Speaker 1: Let's go to Dave from Northern
California. Dave from Northern California,
welcome to the program. Would love
to hear what is on your mind today.
Dave from Northern California, Please
accept my invitation to join the discussion.
Speaker 4: Hi, David.
Speaker 1: Hi.
Speaker 4: How are you today? Okay. I was
calling to talk about your plan to try to
reduce gun violence. Sure, I agree with you. In
principle. I share the same goals. But I come
from the perspective of knowing that there are.
Easily over 100 million semiautomatic firearms.
Most people have at least two magazines. I've
met people who have 100 magazines that are over
the capacity limit that you've talked about in the
past. I don't see how any law that could be passed
would successfully rid the world of the country
of those firearms. And I've got anecdotal cases
for why I think any law would still be
defeated. Evil with current technology. Well,
so how do your apps suppose that would work?
Speaker 1: It's it's not really I mean,
I've already addressed that in the
formulation of my proposal, which is
there is no one law that will solve the problem.
But what we want to do, given that there is a
Second Amendment and given that there are hundreds
of millions of guns out there, we want to see can
we reduce, Can we reduce? And so you're absolutely
right. I mean, listen, part parts of the proposals
are you require licensing, maybe some of the
people I'm sorry, you require insurance. Some
of the people who have a whole bunch of firearms
might say, hey, you know what? I don't want to
pay as much in insurance, so I will choose to
get rid of some of these weapons. You have a
gun buyback program for certain firearms. That
doesn't mean anyone's forced to give them back,
but you give an off ramp to people. So I agree.
I mean, I don't know that we disagree. I'm on the
same page as you there. Given the circumstances
and where we are today, there is no one law that's
going to solve the problem. But what I want to do
is say, is there low hanging fruit that doesn't
violate the Second Amendment that we can use to
help and improve the problem? That's where I am.
Speaker 4: Well. So the reason that
I find that argument unconvincing is
illustrated with an example from close to
me. Last week, a gentleman was arrested
in possession of methamphetamine for sale. He was
a convicted felon and he had a gun on him. That
prompted a search of his home where they located
two more firearms, one of which was a AR 15. That
was one of these ghost guns, although that phrase
is really marked within the gun community. I think
it's better to say a built at home gun from a kit.
And this person was a convicted felon in a state
like California that has restrictions against a
AR 15. This wasn't compliant in any of the ways
that the laws in California. And he made the
gun himself at home. I've seen documentaries
that claim over 150 million blanks have been sold
for making these firearms. So I'm just extremely
pessimistic that that strategy can work.
Speaker 1: Yeah, And like I said,
you're you're sort of proving my point, which
is, of course, you're going to have stories
like that. And you are right. It's possible that
my ten ideas wouldn't have prevented this guy in
California from having built a gun. And I don't
I don't purport to have a solution to that. So,
again, I don't think we're in disagreement.
I think we're up against a real challenge
here. But we can't say, since it won't
solve that problem you just identified,
we should do nothing that I can't get behind.
Speaker 4: Yeah, and I understand that
very much. I guess what I'm trying to do is direct
the conversation towards solutions I think have
any chance whatsoever. And the political.
Speaker 1: Dave, give me give me one such
solution. I've got 40 people waiting, but
give me one such solution we can think
about and then I'm going to move on. Okay.
Speaker 4: Well, that that's the problem is
I don't have one and I haven't completed
what you're saying. It's time to move on.
So thank you very much for taking my call and
congratulations on the birth of your child.
Speaker 1: All right, Dave from Northern
California, great to hear from you